madame monsieur bonsoir bienvenue au 20
heures dominique de villepin a été mise
en examen aujourd'hui dans l' affaire
clearstream une mise en examen assortie
d'un contrôle judiciaire pour lequel
l'ex premier ministre a décidé de faire
appel
pour l'heure il a refusé de répondre aux
questions des juges le temps de prendre
connaissance du dossier
le grand chassé croisé a commencé entre
juillettistes et aoûtiens nous ferons le
point dans ce journal sur les premiers
bouchons de ce week-end qui s'annonce
chargé sur les routes mais aussi dans
les cars et dans les aéroports
le centre commercial de plantes campagne
dans les bouches du rhône sera bien
ouvert dimanche le préfet a reconduit
son accord malgré les récentes décisions
de justice
ce centre est en passe de devenir le
symbole de la lutte syndicale contre le
travail le dimanche victoire pour un
français aujourd'hui dans le tour malgré
une chute sandy casar a remporté l'étape
voilà pour le côté sport et puis pour le
reste les affaires de dopage les citrons
des traces sur ce tour la rupture est
consommée entre les organisateurs et
l'union cycliste internationale vous
entendrez tout à l'heure le président de
l'uci enfin nous prendrons un peu de
hauteur pour terminer avec les
championnats de france de parachutisme
qui se déroule en ce moment dans l'aube
avec une discipline particulièrement
impressionnante le freestyle on commence
avec les suites de la sphère clearstream
dominique de villepin a donc été mise en
examen et il n'a plus le droit depuis
aujourd'hui de rencontrer les personnes
citées dans ce dossier y compris jacques
chirac
l'ex-premier ministre s'attendait à
cette mise en examen mais pas au
contrôle judiciaire
il a donc décidé de faire appel de ce
dernier il n'a pas non plus répondu aux
questions des juges
il souhaite d'abord prendre connaissance
des vingt-sept tomes du dossier
olivier caroff valérie létard grands
sourires et poignées de main
dominique de villepin tenait à se
montrer détendu pour sa mise en examen
complicité de dénonciation calomnieuse
recel de vol d'abus de confiance
complicité d'usagé de faux ça il s'y
était préparé mais les juges
d'instruction lui avait réservé quelques
surprises
deux cent mille euros de caution
interdiction de rencontrer toute
personne citée dont jacques chirac en
moins d'une heure le ton de l'ancien
premier ministre se fait solennel
les habitants je ne vous cache pas que
ces mises en cause
sans douloureuse pour moi et pour ma
famille
mais je me battrai pour que dans le
cadre de l'instruction la vérité puisse
enfin apparaître
je répondrai naturellement à l'ensemble
des questions nouvelles seront tous et
les questions ne manquent pas d'abord
sur ses rendez vous avec le corbeau le
corbeau c'est jean louis gergorin
l'expéditeur anonyme des listings
trafiqués à la justice il dit avoir agi
sur ordre de dominique de villepin et
avoir eu de nombreuses réunions avec lui
sur le sujet deuxième point
l'anc est confiée au général rondot ce
haut responsable des services de
renseignement est le premier à avoir
analysé les listings il a très vite fait
part de ses doutes sur leur authenticité
et plus encore quand le nom de nicolas
sarkozy est apparu
mais dit-il personne n'a voulu le croire
troisième question dominique de villepin
avait t-il reçu des instructions du
président jacques chirac
oui selon jean louis gergorin le général
rondot l'ancien premier ministre le nid
comme il conteste toute tentative de
manipulation je tiens à redire ce matin
car aucun moment je n'ai demandé d'
enquête sur des personnalités politiques
qu'à aucun moment je n'ai participé à
une quelconque manoeuvre a déjà entendu
comme simple témoin l'hiver dernier
dominique de villepin devrait donc faire
face une nouvelle fois au juge
d'instruction
la première audition avait duré 17
heures
mais à l'elysée comme à matignon il n'y
a pas eu de commentaires aujourd'hui sur
cette mise en examen en revanche à
gauche comme à droite certains ont
souhaité réagir à ce qu'il est désormais
convenu d'appeler une affaire d'état on
écoute je souhaite et je les dis depuis
longtemps que la justice puisse trancher
en toute clarté j'ai envie de savoir ce
qui s'est passé parce que quelqu'un de
très proche de moi patrick ollier a été
mis en cause a figuré sur sa liste et je
trouve ça tout à fait scandaleuse
j'ai donc essayé depuis le début parce
que c'est ma conception de la justice
d'aider au maximum de ce qu'ils disent
je souhaite que quelle que soit la
juridiction saisie mais français
puissent se tourner la page de la sphère
triste rim qui empoisonne la vie
politique française
surtout la vie politique de la droite
française depuis quelques mois et vous
l'avez compris derrière cette affaire il
ya aussi une histoire d'hommes
l'histoire d'une rivalité politique un
combat entre deux chaises qui au sein
d'un même parti voulait tous les deux
devenir président de la république
aujourd'hui tout le monde en connaît la
fin mais il n'y a pas si longtemps les
choses étaient encore bien différente
arnaud goûter
le premier s'imaginer le dauphin de
jacques chirac
le second n'avait jamais caché son
ambition à la baule ce fut ce jour-là un
duel au soleil une guerre des images
entre un homme qui court et un autre qui
l'attend avec à l'arrivée pour les
photographes
un joli tableau de la cohésion
gouvernementale
mais ce 3 septembre 2005 jacques chirac
est hospitalisé au val de grâce
cet accident va aiguiser leur rivalité
déjà le gaulliste dominique de villepin
et le libéral nicolas sarkozy s'oppose
sur presque tout roule
le droit de vote des immigrés la loi de
1905 la discrimination positive mais à
l'époque il ne faut pas dire désaccord
dans de charme mais plutôt aux époux les
grands sujets il peut y avoir débat il
est normal qu'il y ait débat
mais il est normal aussi qu'il y ait
actions et décisions nous sommes
différents et nous sommes unis
moi je ne vois rien dans le
fonctionnement du gouvernement qui me
conduisent à considérer qu'il ya une
rivalité insupportable entre le ministre
d'état et le premier ministre entre
dominique de villepin et nicolas sarkozy
en avril 2006 la crise du cpe
l'affaiblît au même moment la faire
cuire stream l'éclaboussent dominique de
villepin clame son innocence et comme
nicolas sarkozy il se pose en victime
j'ai été la victime au cours des
derniers jours d'une campagne de
calomnies et de mensonges ignoble il y à
une manipulation
je veux savoir qui est derrière je veux
savoir qui m'a mis là dedans
vous avez des soupçons pourquoi on m'a
mis là dedans et comme on m'a mis là
dedans
trop c'est trop ça vous a blessé
beaucoup
le 4 mai 2006 la conférence de presse
mensuelle du premier ministre attirent
la foule
les questions fusent un seul thème
clearstream dominique de villepin
s'explique le nom de nicolas sarkozy n'a
pas été évoqué en liaison avec de
quelconques d'affaires nicolas sarkozy
maintient sa ligne il veut aller
jusqu'au bout pour moi ce n'est pas un
problème politique c'est d'abord une
question de moralité publique
c'est bien pourquoi je ne transigerai
pas la vérité doit être connue et elle
le sera le mot anglais clearstream
signifie le cours d'eau limpide la
sphère du même nom ressemble davantage
un torrent boueux et fin de l'acte
politique et de la guerre pour le
pouvoir
en tant que simple citoyen dominique de
villepin doit maintenant affronter la
justice
il commence à y avoir beaucoup de monde
sur les routes ce soir voyez ces images
aériennes tourné il ya une demi-heure à
peine au dessus de l'autoroute a7 sud de
lyon c'est l'heure de la grande
transhumance pour ce week-end qui
s'annonce l'un des plus noirs de l'été
les vacanciers de juillet
commencent à rentrer chez eux tandis que
ceux du mois d'août prennent la route
des vacances on compte déjà dans la
vallée du rhône une quarantaine de
kilomètres de bouchons on va voir
maintenant la situation sur l'ensemble
du réseau autoroutier français
voyez la carte c'est le trafic et
l'encombrement a été fourni par notre
point route il ya quelques minutes
c'était donc la situation il ya quelques
minutes à peu près dans la vallée du
rhône les premiers bouchons se sont
aussi formés dans l'ouest avec 6 km en
vendée sur l'a10 14 kilomètres près
d'orléans
et puis sur la route de l'espagne sur
l'a63 on compte déjà 12 km de bouchons
et ça bouchonne aussi vous l'avez vu en
direction de l'espagne avec 9 km en tout
jusqu'à la frontière
alors comme chaque année pour votre
sécurité pour celle des autres les
gendarmes seront particulièrement
présents sur le bord des routes sur
l'autoroute a6 par exemple pour la seule
portion qui traversent le département de
l'yonne une centaine d'entre eux étaient
mobilisés il faut dire que pour les
grands week-ends jusqu'à 50000 véhicules
par jour peuvent emprunter ce tronçon
aurélien rougerie qui traînent trop tard
l'automobiliste a bien aperçu les
jumelles mais il est déjà repéré 170
km/heure la grosse cylindrée de la
gendarmerie capable de rattraper
n'importe quel bolide
c'est lance à sa poursuite
cette fois le contrevenant est un
hollandais et 113 vitesse retenue 164
suspects ont dit vous parlez anglais
respect des meetings franck en france la
vitesse autorisée est de 130
kilomètres/heure sa 26e vous relier à
173 173 of the speed of sound l'amendé
de 90 euros à payer cash allégé de 90
euros
le père de famille va pouvoir reprendre
la route de ses vacances
on a un petit pays chez nous il ya
beaucoup de circulation et on ne peut
pas rouler bien vite ici ici c'est
possible vous avez bien vu et ce
vacancier n'est pas le seul sur ce
tronçon d'autoroute un tiers des
retraits de permis concerne les
automobilistes étrangers des français
modèrent leur vitesse surtout en départs
de vacances mais je dirais que étrangers
se lâche sur nos routes
ils sont pressés de rejoindre le bord de
mer donc on retrouve malgré tout en
période d'été beaucoup d'étrangers en
infraction
nous voulons un petit contrôle du vieux
une semaine après l'accident du car
polonais les contrôles de bus et de
camions sont une priorité
les gendarmes contrôlent surtout ses
disques véritable mouchard des
conducteurs ils peuvent y lire si les
temps de repos ont bien été respectées
car en bus comme en voiture
la fatigue au volant reste une des
causes principales d'accidents et voyez
maintenant les prévisions de bison futé
pour demain et après demain la situation
empire et vire au noir dans le sens des
départs rouge dans celui des retours
il faudra vous le voyez attendre
dimanche pour que cela s'améliore
légèrement avec du orange dans les deux
sens et si vous pensez échapper à la
cohue en prenant le train ne rêvait pas
non plus la sncf attend 3 million et
demi de voyageurs pour ce week-end elle
a prévu de mettre pas moins de 1800 tgv
à leur disposition les plus chargées ce
soir était dans le sens des départs vers
le sud ou vers la côte atlantique
reportage à la gare montparnasse à paris
j'ai bien du père et thomas donzel
il pensait éviter les bouchons sur la
route ils ont eu les embouteillages aux
sons postage complet
les infos et de chiens pour d'autres
c'est plus compliqué bagage plus
poussette plus bébé
la course nature est fatigant mais pour
l'heure il est calé au métro st galler
voilà vêtements
mais à trop courir les vacanciers
risquent l'incident c'est ici au centre
des opérations de la gare que tous les
problèmes sont traités
là c'était un passager qui a embarqué
ses bagages mais qui a pris plus de
temps en gare et le tgv parti et le
passage de l'upa comptait rester à quai
pour ce week-end hors norme les
effectifs ont augmenté 115 personnes
vont se relayer jour et nuit dans cette
tour de contrôle du trafic sur cette
carte
oui qu'on peut suivre tous les tgv de
montparnasse jusqu'à la bretagne les
pays de la loire
bordeaux hendaye et toulouse selon me
convient car oui mais parle de louvain
la sweden 260 tgv au départ de
montparnasse week-end où 281 retour
entre vendredi et dimanche un train au
départ toutes les cinq minutes la même
chose à l'arrivée dans la cohue du
chassé croisé pour certains c'est le
retour de colonies maman est rassuré
nous en charge des bagages accueil
encadrement
c'était finalement une bonne expérience
d'ici à dimanche soir cinq cent mille
voyageurs auront foulé le sol de la gare
montparnasse et on va faire un tour
maintenant sur la situation dans les
aéroports images tournées ici à orly-sud
beaucoup de monde déjà ce sport vous le
voyez même si la journée record attendu
pour dimanche
en tout dans les aéroports de paris on
attend près de 850 mille passagers pour
tout le week-end
alors si vous faites partie de la tribu
des juillettistes comme on dit c'est bel
et bien fini pour vous il faut rendre
les clés ou démonter la tente
aujourd'hui déjà la tristesse et la
nostalgie était visible dans beaucoup de
campings
reportage dans celui de la pointe à
capbreton dans les landes où en plus on
ne peut pas dire qu'il ait fait très
beau pour sa mois de juillet arnaud
comptes philippe dumas y les vacances
terminées pour ces jeunes retraités
imaginer quinze jours dans un mobile
home au bord de la mer forcément dur pur
de plier bagage est-ce que qu'est-ce
qu'on peut mettre
il annonce un week-end rouge voire noir
alors à faire partir ce soir
trop de monde c'est en soi la route à la
fraîche oui oui un peu plus tard autres
nostalgiques le retour tout à fait prêt
parlons en
comme sur la route dans ce camping c'est
le traditionnel chassé-croisé entre
juillettistes et aoûtiens
alors j'attends 224 et 225
voilà c'est tout net la famille noël
vient d'avaler 600 km à dieu perpignan
bonjour le soleil et ses activités d'été
petit préalable monter la tente ça papa
s'en occupe
les petits eux font déjà le programme on
va s'amuser ici nous voilà là mais on va
se promener mais minimum à la plage ici
comme ailleurs les vacanciers viennent
chercher le beau temps
ce camping affiche complet mais dans la
région ce n'est pas le cas de tout le
monde en moyenne moins 30 % de
réservations
une baisse essentiellement du un début
d'été pluvieux pour certains campings ça
va très bien mais ses potes à tout le
monde notamment les gens qui sont dans
le sud dans le nord des landes et ça
fait confrères se plaignent du manque de
fréquentation à quelques centaines de
mètres du camping la plage a retrouvé
son ambiance estivale bikini baigneurs
parasols cette fois ci on l'espère l'été
et lance le centre commerciale de plan
de campagne dans les bouches du rhône
sera bien ouvert dimanche le préfet a
reconduit plusieurs autorisations
d'autres devraient suivre et ce malgré
les défis les récentes décisions de
justice
la cfdt et la cgt se disent prêtes à
attaquer ces dérogations
il faut dire que ce centre est devenu le
symbole de la lutte syndicale contre le
travail dominical
yannick à rossi christophe la rocca
ouvert tous les dimanches et ça
continuera jusqu'à fin juin 2008
le préfet vient d'accorder de nouvelles
dérogations permettant l'ouverture
dominicale à plan de campagne pour
préserver dit il un système qui existe
depuis 40 ans
nous avons cinq mille emplois en jeu sur
la zone j'estime que le rôle d'un préfet
dans un département c'est d'aider les
entreprises en difficulté quand il
s'agit de passer un cap
la plupart des dérogations arrivé à
expiration demain d'autres ont été
annulés par des tribunaux à plan de
campagne pour les salariés comme pour
les employeurs s'est provisoirement la
fin du suspense c'était une pression
quotidienne de savoir s'ils en étaient
ouverts ou non le dimanche
à l'heure d'aujourd'hui on est un peu
plus serein c'est quelque chose qui
existe depuis 42 ans qui a prouvé sa
capacité de créer de l'emploi
sa capacité de créer de richesses
aujourd'hui il faut essayer de voir
qu'est ce qu'on peut faire pour
pérenniser pas dans le futur dans un
cadre plutôt légal la légalité devrait
être examinée très rapidement cfdt et
cgc ont l'intention d'attaquer une
nouvelle fois ci dérogation en justice
pour obtenir que
le tribunal vérifie que ces dérogations
sont bien illégal et qu'il n'y a pas de
solution à continuer à violer la loi
comme cela à plan-de-campagne des
groupes de travail vont plancher sur
l'avenir de la zone tandis que les
parlementaires devraient examiner début
2008 un projet de loi du ministre de
l'économie concernant notamment le
travail du dimanche
alors au delà de l'aspect social ces
ouvertures dominicales pose aussi un
certain nombre de questions économiques
sont elles réellement intéressante pour
les magasins est ce que les clients qui
viennent le dimanche ne sont pas des
clients perdus pour la semaine
et puis surtout s'il ya un surcroît de
chiffre d'affaires à qui profite il
exactement
éléments de réponse avec bruno timsit et
adèle liège la rue des francs bourgeois
dans le centre de paris
ici le dimanche les magasins sont
ouverts en toute illégalité pour
certains grâce à des dérogations pour
d'autres selon les commerçants fermaient
boutique le dimanche serait une
catastrophe économique et on perdrait
quand même quand même moi je pense 30%
le chiffre d'affaires facilement
facilement on travaille très très bien
60% serris compter les immenses en clair
en cas de fermeture les clients du
dimanche deviendrait-il des clients de
la semaine ou du samedi en fin de compte
les clients consomment t-il davantage
quand les magasins sont ouverts le
dimanche
forcément oui forcément on a pu s'en
danse à consommer quand on est attiré
par un magasin ouvert et avec
avec du chaland avec la lumière oui
c'est vrai oui vous réservez une après
midi entre copines pour faire du
shopping
donc forcément vous allez peut-être vous
faire plaisir mais dépenser plus parce
que c'est ouvert le dimanche paston
selon certains professionnels ouvrir ou
fermer le dimanche ne change rien au
volume total des affaires tous les
commerces de rue devait ouvrir tous les
dimanches il y aurait un étalement des
dépenses de six jours sur sept et il
n'aurait pas davantage de dépenses dans
la mesure où le pouvoir d'achat des
français n'est pas extensible
au final 56 % des français sont
favorables à l'ouverture des magasins le
dimanche
mais 75% d'entre eux ne souhaitent pas
travailler ce jour là
bref au delà du problème économique un
choix de société pour l'instant quatre
français sur dix travaillent le dimanche
au moins occasionnellement
c'est une attaque digne d'une scène de
far west à laquelle ont assisté ce matin
les salariés d'un centre commercial à
thiais dans le val-de-marne des
braqueurs ont pris d'assaut un fourgon
blindé ils ont tenté de le faire sauter
à l'explosif mais le chauffeur qui était
à l'extérieur a riposté avec son arme
l' échange de feu des raies durer très
longtemps mais il n'y a pas eu de
blessés de part et d'autre les
malfaiteurs sont finalement repartis
sans butin
fin du périple africain pour le
président français avant de rentrer à
paris ce soir nicolas sarkozy dîne avec
son homologue gabonais omar bongo
ondimba
il incarne à lui seul la longue histoire
des relations entre la france et
l'afrique il est le doyen des chefs
d'état du continent et à ce titre il
accueille donc aujourd'hui son sixième
président français samah soula francis
forget c'est en hélicoptère que nicolas
sarkozy rejoint la réserve naturelle de
mondenard un concentré des précieuses
richesses forestières du gabon être au
coeur de cet autre afrique au visage ou
moins connus une image voulue par le
président français à ses côtés omar
bongo et jane randall une grande
spécialiste des chimpanzés
c'est donc pas simplement que des
africains
ces problèmes du monde entier nous
devons aider les africains à sauver la
forêt
peu avant avaient eu lieu les
retrouvailles avec omar bongo au pouvoir
depuis 40 ans au gabon les deux hommes
se connaissent bien ils se tutoient le
président français nicolas sarkozy l'a
déjà reçu à l'elysée est folle situation
stratégique le gabon convoité par les
états unis et la chine est un pays que
la france soigne mais pour autant on
n'évite pas les questions qui fâchent
comme l'anc est que même la justice
français sur les biens immobiliers
d'omar bongo en france
si à chaque fois qu'il y avait des
enquêtes judiciaires
il fallait qu'on arrête nos relations ne
seraient pas arrêtés simplement du côté
africain
si oui ce que je veux dire
allusion sans équivoque aux ennuis
judiciaires de dominique de villepin
il y a un an nicolas sarkozy avait parlé
de rompre avec les vieilles habitudes de
la françafrique choisir le gabon et le
sénégal pour sa première tournée
africaine signifie que rupture ne sera
pas synonyme de cassure nette est
brutale et pendant ce temps là le
premier ministre françois fillon était
lui à madrid aujourd'hui un engagement a
été pris faire avancer rapidement la
ligne de train à grande vitesse entre la
france et l'espagne
à terme l'idée de relier madrid à
montpellier et donc ensuite au reste du
réseau tgv français à cette occasion le
premier ministre espagnol a remercié la
france pour son efficacité dans la lutte
contre le terrorisme basque à rodez dans
l'aveyron les policiers ont arrêté hier
le chef présumé de l'appareil logistique
de l'êta
il était sous surveillance et a été
interpellé avec trois autres membres de
l'organisation séparatiste basque
par ailleurs du matériel pour explosif a
été retrouvé dans leur appartement
autre personnalité politique en
déplacement à l'étranger aujourd'hui la
ministre de la justice rachida dati elle
s'est rendu près de londres pour
rencontrer l'inspectrice en chef des
prisons anglaises l'équivalent français
de cette fonction n'existe pas encore
mais justement c'est une réforme à
l'étude
le but améliorer le système carcéral
dans notre pays
correspondance maryse burgot ni goose
bay
cette femme blonde aux côtés de labrune
rachida dati l inspectrice en chef des
prisons britanniques
un poste qui n'existe pas en france le
garde des sceaux veut donc le créer il
s'agira d'une personne qui sera sensible
à ce type de sujet et puis vous avez
l'indépendance elle est aussi dans les
actes et les missions qui peuvent être
affiné au contrôleur un contrôleur
indépendant comme cela existe donc en
grande bretagne depuis 1981 ce matin
rachida dati
à visiter sans la presse cette prison
anglaise pour jeunes délinquants une
prison en partie restauré mais il ya
quelques années le racisme et les
suicides des jeunes détenus étaient
fréquents et c'est précisément la visite
puis les recommandations de
l'inspectrice qui ont permis une
amélioration
elle nous reçoit à londres dans des
bureaux déserts ils sont tous en
inspection
notre travail ne se fait pas dans les
bureaux mais dans les prisons au mur
quelques tableaux peints par des
prisonniers le symbole d'une vraie
volonté de voir les droits fondamentaux
des détenus respecter les inspecteurs
peuvent accéder à n'importe quelle
prison sans prévenir à l'avance nous
avons nos propres clés nous regardons
partout sans être surveillés par un
officier de la prison nous avons des
conversations confidentielles avec les
prisonniers
bref nous observons tous bien sûr les
prisons britanniques souffre-t-elle
aussi de surpopulation récemment 1700
détenus ont d'ailleurs été libérés pour
faire de la place et contre cette
surpopulation l'inspectrice ne peut pas
grand-chose mais rachida dati a quitté
londres ce midi plus que jamais
convaincu de la nécessité de créer
france cette fonction au pakistan la
violence a fait son retour à côté de la
mosquée rouge dans la capitale islamabad
un attentat suicide a fait tout à
l'heure au moins 13 morts et c'est
justement cette même mosquée qui avait
été prise d'assaut il ya quinze jours
par les forces de l'ordre faisant au
moins 75 morts chez des militants
islamistes
la course a repris ses droits
aujourd'hui sur le tour de france et
c'est un français qui a gagné l'étape à
angoulême sandy casar avait pourtant
bien mal commencé avec cette chute
provoquée par un chien
vous voyez il a été blessé au fessier
ce qui n'a pas empêché de finir premier
il rêvait de gagner une étape de puiser
des années 1920 mais remporter une
jusqu'à présent et qui tantôt maillot
jaune il reste sur les épaules de
l'espagnol contador
le calme semble donc à peu près est
revenu dans le peloton on parlait
beaucoup moins de dopage aujourd'hui ce
qui n'a pas empêché la poursuite des
contrôles en tous genres contrôles
inopinés bien sûr mais aussi contrôle
réglementaire à l'arrivée nathanaël de
rincquesen clos et le conte c'est
l'endroit idéal pour être sûr de voir le
maillot jaune le contrôle anti dopage
est un point de passage obligé pour le
leader du classement général alberto
contador
pas de photo pas de sourire pas
d'autographe juste un test urinaire et
parfois comme aujourd'hui une analyse
sanguine
depuis le début du tour contador a été
contrôlé à six reprises et ce n'est pas
fini
pasquet contrôlées sont fiables
maintenant
si l'affiché on le saura vite dès
l'arrivée du peloton les médecins du cia
temps de les contrôler leur liste est
prête
chaque jour le vainqueur de l'étape et
le maillot jaune passe à l'antidopage
ainsi que quatre coureurs tirés au sort
même si les médecins ne veulent pas
parler dans la caméra ils m'ont confié
qu'en ce moment le hasard faisait
vraiment bien les choses
depuis le début du tour 384 contrôles
ont été effectués 225 était inopinée de
tricheurs ont été attrapés une
statistique qui régit les coureurs des
contrôles inlassable inopinés sanguins
et urinaires
on arrive à trouver ça fait mal et c'est
un mal pour un bien
en cas de contrôle positif la
gendarmerie prend le relais l'hôtel du
coureurs incriminés comme ici celui
l'équipe cofidis avant-hier est
littéralement pris d'assaut par une
section spécialisée dans ce genre
d'affaires les issues sont surveillés
les poubelles isoler les chambres
fouiller chez cofidis
les gendarmes étaient là à l'heure mais
avec vinokourov et rasmussen
les coureurs étaient partis avant
cette semaine les performances d'alberto
contador seul coureur capable de
résister à rasmussen ont jeté le trouble
pour certains suiveurs du peloton
l'espagnol dont le nom circulait dans l'
affaire puerto
même s'il a été blanchi de tout soupçon
reste l'objet de quelques suspicions
moi je n'inviterai pour qu'ils puissent
d'un un grand grand vainqueur du tour de
france à
prendre son adn pour qu'il soit
définitivement sorti de cette suspicion
de l' affaire puerto
par exemple à angoulême alberto contador
a débuté sa campagne de séduction
quelques fleurs pour conquérir le public
en attendant de conquérir son premier
tour de france à paris cette édition
2007 restera donc marqué par les
affaires de dopage à nouveau diront
certains mais cette fois il ya peut-être
une chose qui a changé pour la première
fois la rupture est consommée entre les
organisateurs du tour de france et les
instances internationales du cyclisme
les premiers accusent les seconds de ne
pas jouer à fond le jeu pour éradiquer
le fléau du dopage les seconds ont
répondu en exclusivité pour france 2
christophe duchiron julia benedetto
aussi violent qu'un règlement de comptes
a le p ô sur une route de montagne
il ya le conflit du moment et qui
couvait depuis un temps entre la
direction du tour de france à esso et
l'union cycliste internationale à coup
sûr des artilleurs de la parole qui
porte des chemises à peine froisser la
veste à l'épaule a dit pat mcquaid
président de l'uci qui étaient à bord de
cet après midi et qui sera au départ du
tour demain s'est il exprimé pour la
première fois depuis le début des
affaires mon opinion c'est que le tour
de france n'appartient pas à christian
prudhomme à patrice cleyrat esso il
appartient à la famille du cyclisme aux
coureurs et aux publics
quand l'organisateur du tour christian
prudhomme part d'un système il accuse la
fédération internationale de cyclisme et
son président
il faut un système qui défendent les
grandes épreuves qui sont qui sont
l'essence même du sport cycliste qui ont
fait la légende de ce sport depuis plus
de 100 ans
le système actuel est une faillite
absolue
on en veut plus il est vrai que les
relations entre la hes-so el-hussein
sont pas bonnes les organisateurs du
tour ont profité des trois semaines de
course et de la présence des nombreux
journalistes pour attaquer lucet y est
la plupart de ces attaques ne sont pas
fondées sur le cac rasmussen christian
prudhomme considère que lui sait y
aurait dû écarter le coureur danois
avant le début du tour pour s'être
soustrait à un contrôle inopiné
je suis sidéré par le fait qu'un
président de fédération nationale ne
respectent pas les règlements de sa
propre génération
on a fait tout notre possible pour que
le tour de france soit propre et
correcte le fait que deux coureurs se
soit fait prendre positive trouve au
contraire que le système de lucé y
fonctionnent actuellement dans sa lutte
contre le dopage est made of the night
les deux watts pour l'instant bordeaux
la route les coureurs passent ils public
entend passer au dessus de sa tête des
noms d'oiseaux c'est moins passionnant
qu'une belle échappée mais que
voulez-vous en ce moment sur le tour
tout fout l'camp et alors delà de cette
rupture entre le tour et les instances
internationales du cyclisme ces récentes
affaires de dopage ont surtout casser
encore un peu plus l'image du sport dans
le monde de ce sport et pour comprendre
l'ampleur des dégâts nous avons
interrogé et les passionnés chez nos
voisins européens
voyez le regard écouter leurs sentiments
ils ont été recueillis par nos
correspondants dans les grandes
capitales commentaires amaury guibert
sur les routes de kehl en allemagne
david fait c'est 80 km tous les jours un
cycliste amateur qui préfèrent pédaler
plutôt que rester devant sa télé
ils savent que c'est qu'un tour de
france tchad avant je regardais
volontiers le tour à la télé mais
maintenant je trouve ça moins
intéressant parce que la plupart du
temps ils sont dopés on a l'impression
que ce n'est plus vraiment du cyclisme
la seule chose qui compte au nord c'est
l'argent à rome sous un soleil écrasant
on n'est pas loin de partager le même
avis chez lazzarotti fameux marchand de
vélos de la capitale italienne
les petites reines sont bichonnés le
tour de france lui est traité avec moins
d'égards sarah borwell auxerre serait
bien d'arrêter le tour de tout annuler
et de recommencer à zéro
mais ce n'est pas possible il y a trop
d'intérêts qui gère trop d'intérêts en
jeu et non serment solo alors pour vous
le jeu est faussé
il a toujours été à l'ombre d'où le tout
réparti au début du mois certains
veulent encore y croire
allez est-ce qu'elle avait jusqu'au bout
du compte tout ira pour le mieux
cette année c'est terrible pour le tour
beaucoup de gens ont perdu confiance
mais je pense que c'est sans doute un
tournant
les plus optimistes en europe
il faut aller sur les plages espagnoles
pour les trouver ce qui s'est passé
comment et pourquoi est il faudra qu'on
nous explique plus tard et pour le
moment le tour il faut qu'il aille
jusqu'au bout
mais ici on est un petit peu juge et
partie l'actuel maillot jaune est en
espagnol aux transports on va prendre de
la hauteur maintenant avec les
championnats de france de parachutisme
il se déroule actuellement à
brienne-le-château dans l'aube
et depuis quelques années une nouvelle
discipline a fait son apparition
particulièrement spectaculaire cela
s'appelle le freestyle attention ça
décoiffe clair les cinq laurent des bois
âmes sensibles s'abstenir
valérie duchatel est championne de
france de parachutisme et veut conserver
son titre ce week-end sa catégorie le
freestyle une discipline entre la
gymnastique et la danse à 250 km
valérie a le coeur bien accroché sur
terre justement la danseuse étudie la
cardiologie avec le parachutisme elle a
trouvé son équilibre
voyager rencontrer des gens sortir du
milieu médical quatre lieux un petit peu
confiné et puis parce que c'est toujours
agréable d'être en l'air on se sent
libre il n'y a pas de contrainte la
discipline se pratique à deux valérie
fait de la chute libre avec thomas
depuis 2004 elle c'est la grâce et
l'élégance et lui c'est la technique
sans mon casque voilà je l'avais sur la
dette des usa
à terre ces gestes paraît simple mais
leur répétition est primordiale car à
4000 mètres d'altitude la tête en bas le
coeur à l'envers
tout se complique une façon de se
concentrer puis de bien synchronisés
être sûr que comparé bien sûr les mêmes
choses avec la même idée que l'on a bien
les mêmes idées en tête
la vidéo est le seul témoin de ce qui
s'est passé dans les airs les juges
observe le saut 45 secondes au total
pour réaliser figures libres ou imposées
selon les manches
le jury donne ensuite une note allant de
1 à 10 comme au fait y nagent artistique
pour l'heure l'équipe de thomas et
valérie est en tête des championnats de
france
leur objectif devenir champion du monde
en 2008 est toujours en laye rien ne va
plus à la nasa la célèbre agence
spatiale américaine a tenu une
conférence de presse aujourd'hui pour
s'expliquer sur deux scandales
le premier un ordinateur destiné à la
station spatiale internationale a été
saboté une enquête a été ouverte
et puis le deuxième et non des moindres
il s'avère qu'un certain nombre
d'astronautes ont parfois un peu trop bu
en vol
il emporte de l'alcool dans l'espace et
le problème c'est qu'un rapport révèle
qu'à deux reprises au moins ils auraient
été autorisés à partir en mission alors
qu'ils étaient ivres une enquête là
aussi a été ouvert pouvoir au volet il
faut choisir
boire un verre et écouter du jazz en
revanche il n'y a pas de
contre-indication surtout au festival de
sancerre il a lieu en ce moment
aaron transit cia roussel
à flanc de coteau quelques notes de jazz
mais surtout des vignes à perte de vue
normale au pays du sancerre la musique
ne touche pas la soif en ville les
cartons de bouteilles se portent des
deux bras le droit le gauche c'est ce
qu'on appelle de la stéréo
c'est qu'ici le touriste vient avant
tout où ruth et le vin en général et du
jazz un peu aussi en cherchant le bain
pendant une semaine au bord de la loire
la musique se déguste sans modération à
la conquête d'un public pas forcément
jazzy au départ quand les gens ne
connaissent pas et qu'ils écoutent un
gobelet qui sont là pour boire un verre
et bois on est content qu'il en soit on
y va et on n'y a que là il reste
et là c'est vrai que c'est plaisant
c'est vraiment le salaire de la bonne
humeur dans le presbytère du village
bévinda la chanteuse de fado a pris la
place du curé du culot il en faut dans
sa voix un grand monsieur 15 millions et
son poinçonneur des lilas dans les
meilleurs jeux fait des trous des p'tits
trous encore des petits trous j'ai
beaucoup écouté effectivement pour
m'imprégner de sa personne de ses
intentions et ensuite je m'en suis
complètement détaché ensuite je l' ai
mis de côté et j'ai trouvé mon propre au
souffle
un chaudron
des grands travaux aux filles du bon
vivre qu'il connaissait si bien gaz bora
beaucoup plus fous
seize ans après sa mort ses textes ou
toujours dans nos oreilles comme le plus
délicieux des breuvages
nous
me tente
fin de ce journal merci de l'avoir suivi
tout de suite la météo isabelle martinez
ensuite votre point route en temps réel
avec julien pascal à 20h50 c'est de la
musique avec le tube des tubes très
bonne soirée sur france 2 et puis quand
à moi je vous retrouve à demain 13h
on